Florida Governor Ron DeSantis still has
not even announced that he is joining
the Republican presidential primary and
his candidacy continues to collapse well
hold on if it hasn't started how is it
collapsing the answer is recent polling
you have to see this it it's actually I
don't know that we've ever seen anything
like this the green line on your screen
pointing down is Ron desantis's polling
and I'll give you the numbers if you're
just listening today the purple line
near the top is Donald Trump's which
continues to climb
something happened right around March 28
29th 30th that has sent Donald Trump's
Republican polling up and Ron desantis's
Republican polling down and this just so
happens to have been the moment where we
learned Donald Trump would be indicted
and arrested yes I continue to believe
that the arrest and indictment of trump
does nothing for him if he makes it to
the general election in November of 2024
but it is undeniably clear that it is
doing something for him in the
Republican primary Ron DeSantis now down
barely to 20 percent on average in
recent polling he had reached as high as
32-33 and Donald Trump continues to
climb now holding 55 of the Republican
primary ballot uh understanding also
that a bunch of the support is among
people who aren't even running at this
point in time Mike Pence has nearly six
percent but he's not running at least
not right now Tim Scott has two percent
has not yet announced the candidacy
Larry Elder has a one point Chris
Christie has one point Christy may run
Hutchinson just shy of one point uh and
sununu seven tenths of a point so what
does this mean well this means that
unless Ron DeSantis can take support
from people currently supporting the
failed former president Donald Trump he
has no path to the nomination even if
Ron DeSantis Scoops up every bit of the
non-trump vote that only gets him to 45
percent of the Republican primary ballot
not enough to win that nomination so the
question then becomes
how can DeSantis take voters that are
already supporting Donald Trump and the
answer may be he can't that it's really
up to Trump to mess this thing up for
himself that's one perspective uh the
ways that it could get messed up for
Trump for lack of a better term
could include more arrests and
indictments that definitively take him
off of the campaign Trail
some kind of misstep but I mean listen
he's been found liable of sexually
assaulting and defaming a woman and his
support just keeps climbing among
Republican voters so I actually don't
know what there is that DeSantis could
do what I can tell you won't help
DeSantis is the wishy-washy approach
that he has taken where he'll sort of
criticize the failed former president
Trump but he really stands for nothing
and he won't seriously do it this is
just one example we looked at this
earlier this week and of course I
apologize to those who have seen this
here is DeSantis asked do you
acknowledge Trump really did lose in
November of 2020 do you acknowledge that
the voter fraud that Trump claims took
place didn't actually take place and
DeSantis standing for nothing take a
listen to this
GOP needs to project a culture of losing
do you acknowledge that Trump lost and
there wasn't all this raw that he talked
about right well I look at the last
however many election Cycles 2018 we
lost the house true we lost the Senate
2020 Biden becomes president or no
excuse me we lost the senate in 2020
Biden becomes president and has done a
huge amount of damage very unpopular in
2022 and we are supposed to have this
big red wave in other states like
Florida and Iowa I didn't see a red wave
across this country and so I think the
party has developed a culture of losing
I think that there's not accountability
and I think in Florida we really showed
what it takes uh okay I won't play the
whole thing and torture you all with Ron
DeSantis
um this is not inspiring confidence that
is not going to bring over the Trump
people who want to hear him say Trump
did win and this is not going to bring
over the non-trump people who might want
to hear him say listen we lost I wish we
would have won but he lost and I'm
running so that we can actually win it's
not going to convince anyone also an
unforced error for Ron DeSantis is he
keeps going with this anti-woke stuff
which might play okay among Florida
Republicans but when you pull the
country the country is not anti-woke in
the way that Ron DeSantis is acting as
they are here is uh DeSantis yesterday
talking about a Banning gender studies
what this Bill is saying is you know
some of these Niche subjects like
critical the word is Niche sir Niche
this Theory other types of D Niche E.I
infused courses and Majors Florida's
getting out of that game if you want to
do things like uh gender ideology go to
Berkeley go to some of these other
that's fine
it's fine
yeah and by the way I understand that
both both Niche and Niche are acceptable
pronunciations in 2023 for that word uh
that we people have the country has been
pulled okay and it's not at all evident
that just because Junkin won in Virginia
on this uh you know anti-anti woke
campaign platform uh and because
DeSantis did well in Florida it is not
at all clear that that is going to win
you a presidential election or even a
Republican primary nationally because
for the most part the country by roughly
a 60 40 margin is on the woke side of
things so to get back to our question
you look at the numbers you see the
DeSantis collapse what can turn it
around
DeSantis May believe
that simply announcing a run is going to
turn this around
he may be right that announcing that he
is running might push him from 20 to 25
in the Republican primary it might push
him from 20 to 28 maybe even to 30 in
the Republican primary but you don't win
with that and it is not at all clear
that he has a path to denying Trump the
roughly 50 plus percent that he needs so
things not going well for Ron DeSantis
things going very well for Donald Trump
in the Republican primary Rumor Has It
DeSantis if he is going to announce
maybe doing so in the next seven to ten
days we will watch it I will of course
let you know one of our sponsors today
is Bon charge I have always enjoyed dry
saunas you get in there your heart rate
is up dilates the blood vessels can
soothe achy joints and muscles it's
relaxing it's just a great way to remove
a little stress Bon charge is the
creator of the infrared sauna blanket
which you can enjoy from home super easy
to set up heats up fast you don't have
to have your head inside like at a
traditional sauna at the gym nice for
meditating or reading getting work done
relaxing I have found it to be a great
way to unwind at the end of a long day
easy to clean Sleek lightweight design
easy to store and comes with a 12 month
warranty and of course if you don't love
it returns are super easy but I think
you will love it and you'll get 15 off
when you go to boncharge.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
down below